Kylie Jenner sets the record straight on
all those plastic surgery rumors it's
stuff that I would never want to choose
to share in a million years but deep
down like I would love my true fans to
know all my personal stuff the makeup
Mogul covers the latest issue of
homegirls magazine and clarifies all
that gossip about going under the knife
saying that a big misconception about
her is that she's had so much surgery on
her face and that she's an insecure
person I know people say things all the
time Kylie tells the mag yeah I love
full lips and wanted full lips but
growing up I was always the most
confident person in the room I was the
girl performing for everyone of course
fans of Keeping Up with the Kardashians
remember in 2015 Kylie played Coy when a
reporter asked her about the secret to
her signature pout when we asked our
remix readers what what they wanted to
know from Kylie is they just said she
has the most just amazing lips tell us
her secret how does she get these
beautiful lips
lip fillers it's just an insecurity of
mine and it's what I wanted to do I'm
ready to talk to reporters about my lips
yet because everyone always picks us
apart and she elaborated on all that a
few years later during the keeping up
reunion in 2021 I think my love for
makeup started with my insecurity with
my lips I had really small lips and I
didn't ever think about it until I had
one of my first kisses and a guy said to
me oh my God you're such a good kisser
we have such small lips or something
like that and then from then from then
on I felt
unkissable then I got an obsession with
makeup because I would over line my lips
and it just made me feel confident well
we all know that love for makeup made
Kylie a billionaire in 2019 when she
sold 51 of Kylie Cosmetics it's not like
that was handed to her she figured that
all out she made her own money for over
a decade she put it in the bank she
saved every nickel and then when she
decided on what she wanted to do she
spent her money on a venture that could
have gone south or north and it did
really well as for what Kylie calls that
lip insecurity thing she says she fixed
it with filler and it was the best thing
she's ever done I don't regret it but I
always thought I was cute I'm obsessed
with it and Kylie says that becoming a
mom has changed her approach to Beauty
my daughter looks like me I get to see
my beauty in her and it's made me love
myself more of course Kylie shares two
children with with her on and off Beau
Travis Scott five-year-old daughter
stormy come give me big hug
I love you Mommy
forever and one-year-old son air who was
originally named wolf and I liked the
name I don't think anything I still like
this I love it I love it I like wolf I
just wasn't him and when it comes to the
Future Beauty advice she'll share with
stormy Kylie says she's perfect the way
that she is be confident always be
confident in yourself
[Music]
thank you